[MUSIC PLAYING]
FLORINA MUNTENESCU: Hello.
I'm Florina Muntenescu
for "The Developer Shop."
This is your weekly update
on the coolest developer
news from Google.
[WHOOSH]
In order to provide users with
the best Android experience
possible, the
Google Play Console
will continue to require that
apps target the recent API
level.
In August of this
year new apps will
be required to target
API level 28 or higher.
And in November,
updates to existing apps
will be required to target
API level 28 or higher.
More details on the post.
[WHOOSH]
Google Cloud's
Apigee team recently
added new data export and
asynchronous reporting features
to the Apigee API
management platform's
analytics capabilities.
They're now available in
beta with more details
and screenshots on the post.
[WHOOSH]
We recently made our
Cloud Speech-to-Text
and Text-to-Speech products more
accessible with more features,
more voices, more languages,
in more countries,
and at lower prices.
Links to get started
are on the post.
[WHOOSH]
Flutter Create is a
contest that challenges
you to build something
interesting, inspiring,
and beautiful with Flutter
using five kilobytes or less
of Dart code.
Whether you're an expert
or a beginner with Flutter,
we invite you to join us
and see what you can create.
We also have over $10,000
in prizes for a few winners.
Instructions and a link for
submitting are on the post.
[WHOOSH]
Please remember to like,
subscribe, and share.
I'm Florina Muntenescu
for "The Developer Shop."
Thanks for watching and
we'll see you next week.
CREW: And action.
FLORINA MUNTENESCU: Hello.
Oh, no.
[LAUGHS]